أُحصي في كتب ابن تيمية، 428 فتوى بالإستبابة ثم القتل،
أحيانا لأتفه الأسباب،
فعنده  على سبيل الذكر لا الحصر،
تارك الصلاة يستتاب،
وان أصر عل ذلك يقتل،
وحتى من يؤخر موعد الصلاة يستتاب، وان أصرّ على ذلك يُقتل،
ومن يجاهر بالنية في الصلاة، يستتاب وإن أصرّ على ذلك  يُقتل...
استمعوا إلى الحويني، وهو يشرح هذه الفتوى الغريبة.
الجهر...، الجهر... بالنية في الصلاة،
شخص يقف للصلاة، كما نسمع بعض الناس،
يقف ليصلّي الظهر او العصر او المغرب اي صلاة خلف الإمام،
الإمام قال الله وأكبر، وهو قال الله وأكبر نويت اصلّي الظهر حاضرا اربع ركعات مأموما لله،
شيخ الإسلام ابن تيمية نقل في الفتاوى الصغرى، التي كانت منشورة قبل،
وهي من خمس مجلدات،
ان هذه بدعة باتفاق الأئمة  الأربعة وجماهير أصحابهم ومن أصرّ بعد البيان ان يفعلها قُتل...
أي أن شخص جاء ليصلّي لله، يقتل لأنه جهر بنية الصلاة،
كي تدركوا مدى تطرّف ابن تيمية واستهتاره في اصدار فتاوى القتل.
يتعرّض الإسلام اليوم  إلى أكبر تحدّ منذ ظهوره،
ومواجهة هذا التحدّي تستوجب مساءلة نقديّة لنصوصه التأسيسيّة،
لإعادة صياغة خطاب ديني تنويري متصالح مع التاريخ
على المسلمين تحرير عقيدتهم من الكهنوت الديني المهيمن على مقدّساتهم،
منذ الهزيمة الفكريّة والسياسيّة للمعتزلة أمام الحنابلة والأشاعرة،
بعد معركة حامية الوطيس إمتدّت من القرن الأوّل إلى القرن الخامس للهجرة،
عندما أصبح النص القرآني وبإرادة سياسيّة نصّا مفارقا لحياة المسلمين،
وأصبح لأهل الحلّ والعقد وحدهم مشروعيّة تأويل مقاصد هذا النصّ المفارق،
ثمّ يسلّطون على رقاب المسلمين سيف ” الإجماع ” الموهوم
على المسلمين،
إعادة النظر في كتب السيرة وفي كلّ الأحاديث المرويّة عن الرسول،
ليس على قاعدة السند،
بل على قاعدة تطابق متنها أي مضمونها مع العقل والمنطق والقيم الإنسانية كذلك.
لنأخذ مثلا،
الحديث  الذي رُوي عن الرسول،
والذي يستند اليه الإرهابيين لسفك دماء الأبرياء،
والذي قال فيه لنفر من قريش؛
"أَتَسْمَعُونَ يَا مَعْشَرَ قُرَيْشٍ: أَمَا وَالَّذِي نَفْسُ مُحَمَّدٍ بِيَدِهِ، لَقَدْ جِئْتُكُمْ بِالذَّبْحِ".
هل يعقل؟
ان يصدر مثل هذا الكلام،
عن نبي قال عنه النص القرآني انه جاء رحمة للعالمين.
النصوص مهما كانت عظمتها،
عندما تقرأها العقول الصغيرة تتحول بالضرورة إلى نصوص صغيرة.
الإرهابيون، لا يستندون في تبريرهم لجريمة الذبح المقدّس على فتاوى ابن تيمية،
وبعض ماورد في كتب السيرة عن الصحابة والتابعين فحسب،
بل يعتمدون كذلك على النصّ القرآني ذاته،
مثل الآية الواردة في سورة محمد والقائلة؛
" فَإِذَا لَقِيتُمُ الَّذِينَ كَفَرُوا فَضَرْبَ الرِّقَاب..."
هذه الآية نزلت في سياق معين،
وتتحدث عن المواجهة العسكرية في المعارك وقتئذ،
وليس عن قتل الأبرياء غدرا في كل زمان ومكان،
وكل الكتب المقدسة دون استثناء تضمنت نصوصا تدعو للعنف والقتل،
نجد على سبيل المثال في الكتاب المقدّس عند اليهود و المسيحيين،
في سفر التثنية (من الإصحاح العاشر إلى الإصحاح العشرين)، ما يلي:
" حين تقرب من مدينة لكي تحاربها، استدعها إلى الصلح،
فان أجابتك إلى الصلح، وفتحت لك،
فكل الشعب الموجود فيها يكون لك للتسخير ويُستعبد لك،
وان لم تسالمك بل عملت معك حربا فحاصرها،
وإذا دفعها الرب إلهك إلى يدك فاضرب جميع ذكورها بحد السيف،
وأما النساء والأطفال والبهائم وكل ما في المدينة كل غنيمتها،
فتغتنمها لنفسك وتأكل غنيمة أعدائك التي أعطاك الرب إلهك".
أي انهم ان قبلو الصلح فهم عبيدك و ان لم يقبلو فابدهم عن بكرة ابيهم !!!!
لكن لا يمكن أن نجد اليوم مسيحيا واحدا،
يريد تفعيل هذا الإصحاح  الدموي،
في حين نجد مسلمين يريدون تفعيل آية السيف، لماذا؟
لأن الحداثة في الغرب المسيحي مرت من هناك،
والعلمانية مرت من هناك،
وعصر الأنوار مر من هناك،
وأفكار باروخ سبينوازا، وفولتير، ولودوفيغ فيورباخ،
و إيمانويل كانط و فريدريك نيتشه
وغيرهم من المفكرين والفلاسفة مرت كذلك من هناك.
يجب أن تكون لنا الجرأة لننظر إلى وجوهنا في مرآة التاريخ،
نحن لازلنا فكريا وثقافيا في عصر ما قبل الحداثة.
وما دمنا مصرّين على عدم تحمّل  كُلفة صناعة التاريخ
عبر تصالحنا مع العقل،
سوف نظل على هامش التاريخ.
اشكركم على المتابعة،
والى اللقاء في حلقة قادمة على قناة
أنا أفكر إذن أنا موجود...